my 25 years of being around the NBA and  they are young they have players like  this that missed all of last season  Michael Porter journey can be just as  dynamic as we're expecting as I am  Williams to be that's the potential this  kid has number one for the Nuggets  Michael Porter Jr who had been  considered a top flight candidate would  have been someone in the top five he  needed water back surgery was a  first-round draft pick a Denver 14th  overall that sat out all of last season  recovering from back surgery Hayes just  picked up foul number three welcome to  the league quarter junior all your  frustration all your hard work is paid  off here in the box score and more  impressive you let the play come to you  nice off the triple threat fake to the  baseline middle left-hand layup  let them know you got game